bêtement mais ça ne se vend pas je ne
sais pas réellement mais ma première
s'est longtemps c'était
[Musique]
je ne sais même plus je pense que
c'était à l'époque du
lee fait parce que je suis encore jeune
quand même et c'est avec mon amoureux de
l'époque donc du coup voilà c'est un
petit repas tranquillement en amoureux
binger à temps plein personnes viennent
me voir on désespère pas voilà je trouve
que ça arrive
[Musique]
de fou de faux
sans parachute
en couple
j'aurais acheté une grosse voiture et on
aurait roulé roulé jusque jusqu'au petit
matin
se lever à minuit je le rivet je lui dis
bon y'a on est attendus quelque part et
puis mon slam va
parce que je suis assez fou
prenez une île no frills genre cool à ça
je l'aurais permis d'accéder à ses
souhaits et ses rêves tous ces petits
des yeux étant donné les circonstances
actuelles je pense que ça serait partir
en voyage la l'heure actuelle on peut
considérer que s'est il vraiment à me
faire ça je partirai en voyage je ferai
ça au tec hôtel cinq étoiles
all inclusive tout ça aurait fait ça
en tout cas pour essayer avant thymiques
je crois qu'à une destination pour ne
pas faire de publicité que j'aimerais
envisagée c'est dans les arbres enfin je
ne dis pas plus et puis je me ferais
jeunes move et servir quelque chose de
deniers copieux de bien goûteux
quelque chose de fou
j'ai pas que tout est quasiment fait on
était dans un passionnant golf hier
[Musique]
non
serkan a beaucoup il y en a une que
j'aime particulièrement ce et de francis
kpn je t'aimais je t'aime c'est une
chanson que nous sortons souvent à la
maison c'est je t'aimais je t'aime et je
t'aimerai de francis cabrel et quoi que
tu fasses
l'amour est partout où tu regardes
[Applaudissements]
bon ni l'un ni l'autre plantes plantes
fleurs
les élus semblent chandelle
en tête à tête
bon une fois en tête à tête
[Musique]
pour moi
caveau pour lui
[Musique]
jogging
nu ni deux
[Musique]
que l'amour c'est beau
qu'il faut savoir partager profiter de
l'instant présent
[Musique]